Let's go to our caller from the eight oh three
area code.
Who's calling today from eight Oh three?
Yes.
Hello?
Yeah.
Who's this?
Hi, I'm, I've been on, um, yes, I'm from NATO,
Pretty Columbia, South Carolina and I'm a
student at University of South Carolina, I
believe is about three on m.
And.
M. I've been wondering what were your thoughts
on
yeah,
the current wealth gap in our society and
lately in my classes, and we've been talking
a lot about, uh, a lot about pretty much a
fascism or a war because of the wealth gap
is so wide now.
And I wanted to get your opinion on that.
Do you think those are really two options,
but do you think you're, we're heading down
one or the other?
No, no.
I mean, listen, successful social democracies
that, that properly and aggressively regulate
capitalism, uh, have reduced wealth gaps significantly.
They've brought up the bottom, they've put
some limits at the top and we know that there
are all sorts of intangible benefits to reducing
the wealth gap.
Not only do you bring more people into the
sort of, uh, participate in class, as I like
to call it, people who are enabled to participate
in society and in the things that the, the
institutions of society, um, reducing inequality
reduces crime, reducing inequality has all
sorts of intangible positive affects societies
work better when you have lower levels of
inequality.
The economy is more stable when you have lower
levels of inequality because the sort of purchasing
power is not so concentrated one end, uh,
among Sophia people.
So I don't think that war or fascism are the
only path forward in an unequal society.
I think that the Scandinavian economies are
proof of that.
Uh, I think that there are other, uh, economies
that are proof of that.
And I think that the, that that's not the
only path forward.
Oh yes.
I, I told, I agree with you about, you know,
be social democracy such as in Hawaii, inland
and you know, the Swedes, but also I just
wouldn't know, I guess maybe pertaining to
America, you know, unlike goes countries,
we don't invest heavily in a social programs
such as like education or teacher pay is to
keep a clear dialogue.
So as far as, I guess with the, the current,
uh,
you stagnate the status quo and the United
States, what are the paths forward here?
Yes, yes.
For the United States because even in the
past, like, you know, I guess even outside
of the United States, but with Germany or
even when we were at this point and for in
the beginning of World War Two, we would have,
you know, the wealth gap was huge and everyone
was desperate and we decided to go war.
Right.
And here's the thing, here's the thing in
the United States.
So we'll think about the United States more
specifically.
The desire among the voters is already there.
Basically for economies that look much more
like the Scandinavian economies, you ask people,
should the government provide a basic level
of healthcare to everybody, even if they can't
pay two thirds to three quarters of Americans
say yes, should the United States tax the
very rich in order to reduce income inequality?
Majority of the country says, yes, I could
go on.
Okay, so the voters already want that stuff.
The problem we have in the United States is
that the desires of the rich and of big corporations
are overwhelmingly likely to be made into
law by our elected officials compared to if
you're just a random middleclass guy who goes,
so yeah, we need to fix the political system.
Fascism I don't think is going to get us better
teacher pay and the other things that you're
talking about and wars?
No, definitely not advocating for it.
No, no you're not.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you for the call.
Very important stuff and I think that there,
the desire is there.
We just need to make it a reality by fixing
the system.
We have campaign finance as part of it, media
consolidation as part of it.
We've talked about all of the things that
need to happen and they're, they're big things,
but a fascism and war or certainly not the
paths forward.
Thank you David.
And I keep up the good work too.
I love your show and I'm going to tell you,
listen,
thank you.
Really appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.